good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
president of the euro chamber
representatives of the singapore
government
and of the diplomatic community
it is a great pleasure for me to address
you today all bite from a great distance
i would like to start by thanking the
european chamber of commerce
for this invitation and for its valuable
work
with the european business community in
singapore
today's event shows that you are not
only promoting closer
economic relations between singapore and
the european union
but also fostering sustainable
businesses
and that is farsighted and wise
the european union and singapore may be
far apart
but we are close partners
when the coronavirus crisis hit us all
our free trade agreement was our anchor
during the pandemic total trade between
singapore and the european union
only decreased by four percent
and exports from singapore to the
european union
even increased by 24 this
is really amazing and this shows the
full potential and power
of global cooperation
we are also united in our efforts
to look after our planet our free trade
agreement
is the first trade deal with a
sustainable development chapter
for instance the deal incentivizes
companies
to use natural resources sustainably
preserving rather than destroying our
environment
so europe and singapore are working in
parallel
on the path towards a greener economy
this comes at a crucial moment in time
over the next two years governments
around the world will seek to spend
around
10 trillion euros to finance the
economic recovery
but this time it must be a green
recovery
after the financial crisis of 2008
global co2 emissions reached a new high
this recovery was fully fueled with
carbon heavy investment
today the world simply cannot afford to
make the same mistake
a green recovery is good for our planet
and for our economies and this time
europe is determined to do things
differently
the european green deal creates
thousands of new opportunities
science tells us that every million
euros
invested in clean energy creates
three times more jobs compared to
investment in fossil fuel powered energy
so this is the moment to make a
very clear choice for sustainable
and clean investment during
the summer i have proposed a
european recovery fund called
next generation eu it is worth
750 billion euros
37 of next generation eu
will be spent directly on climate action
so let me give you a few examples about
how we intend to do this first
we will launch a renovation wave for our
buildings
similar to singapore's green towns plan
we want to make our buildings more
energy efficient
and we want them to become carbon sinks
using organic building materials like
for example wood
and smart technologies powered by
artificial intelligence
with next generation eu we can make
europe's buildings less wasteful
less expensive and more sustainable
second we will invest in clean hydrogen
hydrogen is a perfect alternative to
fossil fuels for heavy industry
clean hydrogen must not only be produced
but transported stocked and it has to
become
part of industrial processes
so next generation eu will invest
specifically in this systemic
transformation
third we will finance one million
electric charging points
across our continent these are
investments in green
infrastructure that accelerate change in
the mobility sector
so next generation eu has the potential
to create
new markets for clean products
and for sustainable products
the european green deal is our ambitious
plan
for a more sustainable future
and at the same time it is europe's new
growth strategy
the fact that the european union will
lead the way
will also create opportunities for our
partners
and sustainable businesses worldwide
just look for example at green financing
30 of next generation eu
will be raised on capital markets
through green
bonds so international investors will
know that
if they invest in europe they invest in
our planet's health
as well as in the competitiveness of our
economy
and the health of our society
so you are all invited to join
the recovery has to be sustainable for
the next
generations
but let me be clear none of us
can fight climate change alone we can
only do this together
2021 should be the year when the whole
world
agrees on more ambitious targets for
example at cop 26 in glasgow
next month i hope that europe's leaders
will agree on
our proposal to reduce
eu greenhouse gas emissions by at least
55 by 2030
so this will then become our new
commitment under the paris agreement
as like-minded partners singapore and
the european union
can lead the way together we
can try to inspire our partners around
the world
and we see that change is already
happening
in recent weeks important economies such
as china
japan south africa and south korea
they have announced some big steps
forward
so this shows that together
we can build a global movement for
climate action
and an innovative climate-friendly
economy
singapore and europe together with other
asean countries
can contribute in building high ambition
coalitions
together we get all of us closer to our
shared goal
this is a task for governments of course
but businesses also have a central role
to play in this
and today's awards show that companies
across europe and
asia are already exploring innovative
solutions
so let me congratulate the winners in
all five categories
circular economy smart mobility
clean and efficient energy
sustainable food and nutrition and
green finance you are front runners
you have understood that a greener
and more prosperous future is possible
you are showing that together
we can make a difference thank you